welcome back to my final recap from
kregero chess I just played my round
nine game against International Master
Marcel efromski and we've actually
played before about a year ago in
Gibraltar and I did a recap video of
that game which I will link below she
beat me in that game so this is my
chance to get revenge leading up to the
scheme I did a bit of preparation and I
knew she plays the Sicilian so I opted
for one E4 and I was really excited to
go into kind of a tricky offbeat line
that actually prepared a year ago in
Gibraltar that I didn't get a chance to
play starting with Knight F3 D6 and then
Knight to C3 and after Knight F6 white
doesn't go for an open Sicilian with the
traditional D4 but rather goes for E5
and I was excited to play this because
I've been preparing this for a while now
but never played this in a tournament so
I thought this would be a nice surprise
weapon and before the game I saw that
she's played this position before and in
none of those games did Black play the
right continuation now I made a very
embarrassing mistake regarding my whole
preparation which I'll explain in just a
moment but let me show the the next few
moves after takes takes she plays A6 and
I play Pawn to G3
and before I show what she played in the
game I just want to share like a few of
the really tricky and trappy
possibilities and there's a move here
for black which looks very natural Queen
C7
and I'm realizing I should probably go
on a tangent to explain like the whole
backstory of how I discovered this
opening because about a year and a half
ago I went to Vegas and met up with a
few chess friends and one of my friends
who's a fide master was telling me the
story about how he beat neriditsky in
one of neriditsky's speedrun videos and
my friend whose rating is like 2300 was
playing on the Smurf account and his
account rating was like 1200 and he
played this opening against neriditsky
nariditsky played Queen C7 and then my
friend Unleashed a really cool sequence
of moves starting with D4 takes takes
Knight C6 takes takes and then rather
than defending the Rook uh Bishop G5 was
played and nerojitski took on each one
and after Queen cycle white is
completely winning here there's threats
of this and this and black is toast so
so I was excited to hopefully get a
similar line in the game just now
the only issue was Marcel was very
well prepared for this line and she very
quickly played the move Queen to D6 here
now I only realized this after the game
because we chatted a little bit but
I told her after the game that I I found
10 games of hers in this line and she's
never played Queen D6 before so I was
wondering if she prepared this before
the game and she told me she's never had
this line with the black pieces but
she's played it a lot with the white
pieces and it turns out I prepared this
whole line
based off her white gains not against
her blackings and let me just share my
chest based window because this is the
program I use to prepare and basically
what I did I found a database of over
700 of her games and I just filtered to
see all her games from this position and
as we see I found 10 of them nine of
them featuring E5 but what I failed to
do was filter out her white games so all
of these games we see on this sidebar
she had the white pieces and
um yeah all my preparation was was
scuffed because clearly if she plays
this as white
she knows what should be the best line
for black
so it's an embarrassing bit of failed
opening preparation
and I don't know what happened I I don't
think I've made this mistake before but
uh if I had to make an excuse this round
did start an hour earlier at 9am rather
than 10 p.m so maybe the
um the extra hour of sleep could have
really helped me
so anyway we got to this position I was
aware that Queen D6 was the best move
and I did check this before the game I
mean this line if if black knows it then
white has really no Advantage but at
least it's still playable and the best
move here I checked the stockfish
beforehand was Knight off three and then
we went into
um of a position where white has a
little bit less space especially after
Pawn E5 but white also has kind of a
very stable setup essentially a king's
Indian attack type setup but without the
four Pawn
so we continue from here D3 Bishop B7
castle castle and I play rookie one so a
lot of these moves very natural then she
plays Pawn H6 which I think is a very
natural move uh generally this move is
played before Bishop E6 because it
prevents Knight to G5 so I go ahead here
and played Bishop to E3 just completing
development and then she plays Bishop E6
so in this moment I realize there's not
much to do for whites because I have
that space and I came to the conclusion
that my best approach would be to trade
and simplify a little bit so I played
Knight to E4 and then she took I took
kind of a flurry of Trades Queen takes
T1 Rook takes D1 I was actually
expecting Queen C7 here but then uh the
play is pretty simple just C3 Queen C2
Knight D2 and I think the position is
still very solid but solid for both
players would be a fight from here but
in the game queens were traded and then
Rooks were traded and then I play C3 and
at this point I was feeling very solid
and I felt like uh yeah the position
should be very close to equal then she
played A5 which was a slight surprise uh
because I thought the more natural
approach would be either B5 or just
patient play with Pawn F6 but after A5 I
decided to play Bishop F1 and offer a
draw simply because I didn't think there
was much chance to to play for a win
here and I did have a slight time
Advantage as well as we can see from the
timestamps and she thought for a little
bit and accepted the draw and I'm happy
to have not lost this game given my
whole opening preparation was just
really scuffed and it's disappointing to
to mess up the preparation in in such a
way because I was really saving this uh
this bit of opening prep for so long I
played it probably against the worst
possible opponent who uh who knows this
line as as whites but um I think overall
it was probably a very solid game I
haven't had a chance to check it
with the engine at least the middle game
uh it's possible I was a little bit
worse out of the opening
if we go back even further but I think
it was pretty much equal throughout okay
engine slightly prefers Bishop G5 maybe
I should have considered
oh black is slightly better after Bishop
G4 I was gonna play H3
ah this is interesting to play Bishop E6
and then Queen D7 and get Tempo on the
pawn yeah so I could have been a little
bit worse
but then after the trades yeah Queen C7
was probably better approach or lack
but then very quickly I think just was
equal
oh white slightly better after Bishop
Athlon
I really didn't see much of an advantage
though like B6 and it just seems like
we're both really solid okay maybe I
have the B5 square but B6 and F6
it should really be close to equal so
anyway uh that's the tournament I
finished with five and a half out of
nine
I'm not sure how it will affect my
rating I'm pretty sure I've I've
performed almost exactly as uh my my
2356 free day rating and overall I feel
like I have a lot of fun games I know my
last couple of games maybe weren't the
most exciting uh ending and pretty
peaceful draws but um also had some
crazy ones I do appreciate all the the
positive feedback in the YouTube
comments and elsewhere it was just such
a pleasure playing this event the
conditions were amazing the hotel was
one of the nicest I've I've stayed in
for a chess tournament uh maybe I'll
have to share some behind the scenes of
my room and the food and the view my
hotel room is actually like a whole
apartment so maybe if I can pack and
clean up quickly enough I'll do a mini
room tour to close out this video but uh
thanks everyone for watching stay tuned
on Twitch I will be returning to live
streaming in the near future and don't
forget to use coupon code Norway if you
want to get merch we still have the
promotion going uh probably for at least
another week after this video is posted
so thanks again and I'll see you guys in
a future video that won't be a recap so
stay tuned
this is going to be the kagero room tour
welcome to my room
it's more of an apartment than any sort
of hotel room we have a really nice sofa
area and
oh look at that view we also have this
thing
which I probably didn't use as much as I
should have but uh yeah let's take a
look at this View
so beautiful waking up
so much natural lights
I see natural light from all directions
from our full kitchen area
just over here
apologies for the mess on the table but
this is where I was streaming with a
window behind me I didn't have the
tripod set up here
and you have a nice kitchen with some
electric kettle before the tea
[Music]